how did you end up uh getting with House
of Payne back in the day before because
I I you I know I know you guys had a
little falling out for a sec but it was
an accident man like I was dating this
girl that actually was cousins of
everlast's DJ and I would go over there
and he'd be at the crib and I'd be like
all right and the Cypress demo disciples
we were signed already but the album I
had the album on a red cassette and I
gave it to her but the album didn't come
out for six months
so the next time I went over there a
couple times Everlast was there he was
listening to the tape he's like yo we
got to get in the studio I was like nah
I'm good man
and after three or four times I was like
I was talking to be real b-rolls like
man just [__] it [__] with him I was
like all right so I went in and put your
head out in the crib and I was like
okay this is cool then the homies was
bumping it and then I was like I got
this song called Jump Around
so I had already recorded it with son
doobie I recorded it with Daddy Freddie
from ragamuffin hip hop and I had a song
I had the hook
he came in and wrote the [__] I was like
now rewrite it with that Cadence right
there and he wrote the [__] and then we
had the joint and to one of the greatest
party songs of all time shop the deal
man I know Funkmaster Flex wanted to
sign us at priority records for like I
think it was like 55 60 G's he had
special ed over there at the time I
didn't even know Funk Flex worked the
priority yeah you say you know crazy and
then um it was weird because Monica
Lynch over a Tommy Boy wanted to sign us
and um so I went and had a meeting with
her and she was like she was Irish so
she's like this reminds me of my family
this is like my brothers would go to
church
then they go to uh to the bar and get
drunk and fight
so she got it right off the bat you know
I mean so she signed us she gave us like
300 back then
and then uh I hooked him up with art
management the guys who did our our
pictures I grew up with those guys and
David Perez who did our video I'll come
up with them so it was pretty much the
formula so you kind of just say here's
our formula run with it run with it and
it worked work with it like a
[__] like a [__] yo I
always wondered so there was like this
era um I'm really close with Dilated
Peoples and raqqa and higher science and
Baboo and obviously shout out I did the
best hell yeah I love those guys
um
they really opened my world uh my taste
in another a whole nother way
um to like digging into like different
[__] that I was into at the time but I
remember as a kid there was the random
because you were close like you were
cool with Paul obviously right you're
cool with M but then there's like this
weird beef between like Dilated Peoples
Everlasting Eminem did you ever try to
like bring those guys together nah it
was weird man I think I think Everlast
from what I remember correctly you know
don't quote me here but I think ever
last seen M on the elevator and M just
didn't say nothing to him but M's like
he didn't look the same right and didn't
realize that he didn't realize who he
was right right and and was a [__]
Everlast fan you know from what I hear
so ever that's just you know I don't
know what happened then he wrote some
[__] about him yeah and then I remember
there was like the dilated [__] and then
evidence had a song called uh Searching
for Bobby Fischer so I was just
wondering because you were kind of like
it felt like I live in Switzerland you
might have you know I don't know if
you're trying to put a call in none no I
just figured all that oh y'all [__] up
yeah you know [__] with them we got
good luck with that [__] man good luck I
mean like even why but um I don't even
think I heard the dilated song ever yeah
there was an Evidence song called
Searching for Bobby Fischer that was
like I heard that one no but I had um a
Napster hit yeah so yeah I brought Paul
I remember when I met Paul I flew him
out to L.A to meet with me and I had a
barbecue um to manage Cyprus and he came
out here and that's how I met Paul
because Theo Theo was my lawyer and I
was like yo I need a new manager bro
what year was this before um before um
rock superstar album so it was like 2099
yeah 99 and I was he's like yo I got
this this lawyer he's got an ear like me
and he's managing this artist Eminem and
didn't blow up here yeah
flew his ass out had a barbecue and
locked in with Paul what what was was it
labeled like why did you guys do a rap
Superstar and a rock superstar
difference because um check this out so
we was up at Columbia and you know now
we're going into the fifth album
so we'd go to the urban Department that
was after the album after Dr
greenthumber before after after that's
right okay it was like yeah that was
four that was the fifth album yeah so we
would go up to the label and was like
all right let's go this marketing plan I
go to the urban Department it was like
no no you guys are you guys are
alternative I know we ain't so we go up
to the other we go up to the next floor
and they was like oh no you guys are the
urban Department
and they didn't work together and
everybody's passing the buck nobody
wanted to do their [__] job and I was
like you my [__] pieces of [__] check
this out I'm gonna give you all a rock
song and a rap song So now what's your
[__] excuse me you got one you got
one so I did we had a song called can't
get the best of me and rap Superstar
and then I walked into the meeting with
Donnie Aina and he was like no this is
the single we're not doing rock song
with this is the single I'm putting all
the money behind this one I was like oh
[__] this ain't gonna work so I went in
the studio a couple days later and did
the remix for black Superstar wow okay